Black Monday this shows hilarious thanks
very edgy it is really funny it is so
easy and fun to watch a bunch in a row
it really yeah it just they just one
leads into the leads into the next leads
into the next it's a it's a very cool
show it's a it takes place in the late
80s that's right before the market crash
and your character I mean it's funny the
they've stretched this reality a little
bit not yeah a little bit but a lot they
touch the reality a lot for comedic
effect yeah but it's larious your
character is he drives what does he
drive well he's driven in he's driven in
a Lamborghini limo yeah and the limbo
yeah a limbo and there's the writing
sometimes the writing and I love it for
this reason it takes it to the edge
sometimes it pushes the edge a little
bit sometimes yeah when you're they're
asking you to say a line you get
uncomfortable because you think it's too
edgy well yeah I mean it's one of those
situations where you have to the show
set in the 80s when everybody was
inappropriate and on cocaine and sexist
and racist and everything and if you
don't bring some of that into the show
especially in the cable setting you know
you're kind of violating the contract
with the the time right so we're always
pushing that but our writers David
caspin Jordan kaha nerd or bananas so
they are always trying to get us to say
worse and worse things I'm like if you
want to swing the camera around and you
guys can say it that's fine but as long
as I have to say it I'm not saying that
anti-semitic joke I'm not doing it right
yeah but to point it out and this is
something that happens a lot in in this
business
I'll have Jewish writers that will write
a joke that's making that that's yeah
they can skewer them so they can skewer
themselves but they'll write it for me
so I'll say no I can't say that no I'm a
Catholic kid from Boston I can't do a
joke that's that even that hints at that
it's not appropriate to be like I say
that stuff all the time it's funny and
I'm like yeah
your name's Rothstein yeah you say that
to your friends in their house exactly
if we want to go to your house and shoot
the scene absolutely yeah yeah well I
don't know where you get time to do all
of this great work
I'm glad you do think we have a clip
here from Black Monday anything we need
to know for this scene
everyone's on cocaine I think this is
the scene where Andrew Rannells
character has just we've just pulled a
prank on him and gotten him arrested on
the floor he's down on the floor of the
stock exchange like you guys pulled a
prank got him arrested now he's come up
and he's really pissed yeah he's really
upset
and we find it cute yeah let's take a
look this clip from Black Monday bet you
didn't think you'd see this me again
this guy me Wow
I am very glad you're here Billy yeah I
would like a tuna fish sandwich hold the
carrots and a Crystal Pepsi anybody know
I'm the guy from the floor with the
cocaine oh hey coke guys here let me get
to a buzzer now what's that new thing
everybody's talking about crack tried to
grab just regular cocaine no let's be
innovative cracks cracks for everybody
guys yeah no one is getting cracks
that's really funny the the first season
of Black Monday is available on Showtime
streaming and on-demand and I have to
say I've run into you I mean I see you
professionally in sort of settings like
this and then I run into this guy a
bunch of times just out in the world and
he's just an incredible class act one of
the nicest people I've met in the
business always like the kind well I
said that's you'd say something nice
about me and it worked it works